une course inédite au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
structure a accueilli ce samedi 2
février une compétition d'une durée de
six heures au total 24 équipes de quatre
coureurs se sont affrontés à coup de
pour soulever la coupe il fallait
parcourir le plus de kilomètres dans le
temps imparti
il faut trouver les bons temps sur la
piste pas s'est déroulé entre
30 minutes 45 minutes passent et un
relais lorsque le concurrent est fatigué
en pis alors il ya toute une train et
une stratégie à adopter
et puis marquer aussi ses adversaires à
la fin des six heures c'est l'équipe de
paris cycliste olympique qui remporte la
compétition avec 1060 tours parcourus
sur la première heure les pistons ont
réussi à atteindre une moyenne de 50
km/heure c'était un objectif qu'on était
venu là pour gagner
on a une super belle équipe avec trois
coéquipiers qui reviennent d'espagne
donc j'étais en forme et on a assuré on
a essayé de faire le show aussi on s'est
fait mal mais tout est bien qui finit
bien ont remporté une belle coupe une
belle victoire chez les féminines
l'équipe auber saint-michel remporte la
compétition avec 255 kilomètres
parcourus pendant ces six heures
nouvelle édition pourrait être organisée
l'année prochaine